dear fellow brothers my name is
PewDiePie I've searched for centuries a
ways to perfect click baits and views
I've scavenged ancient temples to
uncover secrets of popularity with no
talent whatsoever
I've horde myself left and right up and
down and inside out and up and up but
I'm running low I'm running out of ideas
there must be other options boobs in the
thumbnail will only get you so far
surely there's another way I mean what
if what happens when that's it I just
need to make videos of me doing stupid
[ __ ] to my to my phone oh what happens
when you stare at an iPhone
so as you can see there was no damage to
the phone it still works
still works um let's see here
no stupid stupid go away
I'm it's tip go away boy
it's still still dust you can still do
use the calculator don't work you can
still go away you can still you can
still all false I'm strong like happens
when you drop an iPhone it's an iPhone
all right Oh
Oh God skaara
okay okay Maya yeah Jim all right
it still works still works still 100
what happens when I put the phone on an
iPhone it works what happens when you
hit a phone with the hammer
it breaks it breaks if you hit it with a
hammer it breaks if you boil it and it
breaks if you shove it up your [ __ ]
god damnit [ __ ] actually what happens
when you shove an iphone up your [ __ ]
sensors oh I work